字幕志愿者 李宗盛
小朋友 問一下
如果拍這張
你是不是應該要完全的佔有他
完全佔有他
白天佔有他
晚上也要佔有他
這樣很累
可是如果你不顧好會跑掉
真的嗎
有那麼恐怖嗎
不顧好就馬上跑掉了
這不就跟我們今天講的主題有類似嗎
如果你今天明明是你自己的东西
你不顾好
那人家会来抢的哟
对啊
而且人家慢慢抢
有的时候还不知道
然后等你默然回首
哎呀
完蛋了
我的持股不足了
女朋友对狼造
对
那就持股不够
这个老板换人了
好
所以有时候我会觉得
遇到有那种什么董监经营权之争的公司
自己也要检讨一下
对
你怎麼會搞到你持股太低
被別人盯上呢
你平常就是想把一些股票拿去換成現金
不好經營
只想變現
而且在這個金英權之爭
趙華發現自己好像越來越有名
在竹科男的心中
好像有一個故事在喔
因為據說我有一個很久不見的高中同學
在竹科喝咖啡
就聽到我的名字
就竹科男的討論我
然後就在講說我們節目其實有講到
某一檔股票有靜音權之爭
那時候我只是隨口說
我朋友有在想要不要幫忙
你知道那個東京財經的理財
他有介入那個靜音權之爭
有事嗎
再傳下去就是你要去競選
再傳下去我就變董事長
但是靜音權之爭
我們小散戶可不可以吃豆腐
可能今天要麻煩小哥來教我們
通常都是年初的重頭大戲
那我們今天好好來教學一下
好的
欢迎收看理财达人秀的歌有仇必报的单元哦
小哥常常告诉我们一些筹码的变化
今天要来告诉你
如果你真的很爱你的公司
你真的很爱你的伴侣
你的配偶
你要把它顾好来
为什么呢
如果你手上的股权太少的时候
而你的公司有一定的价值
就会引发什么呢
引发经营权之争
董监要来抢改选了
那每年的年初
都是这个经营权之争的
大戏上演时
只是台股说实话
在每年的年初
要开这个股东会的公司
500多家
总不可能每一家
都来给你抢那个经营权
所以今天小哥来教你了
有哪一些的征兆
会让你知道
这一家在抢经营权
那我知道干嘛呢
我知道当然就是要搭便车
我们要如何搭上
抢经营权股价上涨的便车呢
好 這邊要先來請教小哥
到底這個董監改選
董監競監權之爭的起源是什麼好不好
好 那起源呢
這個台灣是個法治的國家啦
所以通常很多事情起源呢
就是在法律上
那董監改選呢
按照公司法第195條第一項
第217條第一項
強制規定喔
董監的任期不得超過三年
比總統少而已
對 而且蠻常選的
三年就一次
不過他可連選連任
可連選連任
他可以一直連任
一直可以連任
三年三年三年連任
他不像我們總統只能選兩次
他可以連任的
那2022年大概有566家
大概每年都是五六百家
好多耶 三分之一耶
對啊 因為三年一次嘛
三分之一啊
就這樣算就好了
原來如此
很簡單
這個每年都有五六百家
會進行董監改選
那也不是說每次改選都會有行情
也對啊 人家有的很滑稠
因為有的它的持股都很夠啊
這個持股沒有問題
股票一堆的
有的公司可能也沒人要
對 有的沒人要嘛
那有的持股足的
它根本也沒有董監改選的困擾
所以我們要去看有沒有董監改選行情
首先很重要的我們要知道
今年到底有沒有選
那你記得
假設今年有選今年2022
下次就2025
很好記
或者你去查他2019年選
那今年就是要選
就三年一次
很好查的
所以董監改選年度
還有董監持有比例
各位你就可以上這個網站
上次网站你就可以去查
查看董监改选年度是几年
持股比例是多少
那要持股比例很高的时候
那可能就没什么行情
混都很高了
温度度
这个爱人不会对狼造
很高是多高才算高
很高多高才算高
这个持股六七十%
你根本不用怕了
因为这个在五十%以上
就还蛮稳的
通常你過50%就是
過50%就夠了
比較害怕這種沒過50%的
或者是裡面有判圖的
因為他不見的是董事長或總經理
他是整個你的外圍有50%就算多了
就是你要控制好你的票
你的票有沒有真心的要投給你
不要等到投票來
哎呀完蛋了
原來他才是情敵
原來他跑了
跑了哇塞這個就慘了
好那董監蓋選行情呢
這個通常要幾個理由啦
沒錯
第一個
有個公司沒人要剛講
公司沒人要啊
這個公司的基本面又差
我要你這家公司
要你這家公司
這個哇塞
這個我還要一直
這個投錢進去
所以這個通常我們就要看一下第一个公司有被青睐的理由好 就是帥哥美女青睞 對 帥哥美女或是有某種資產
對 沒錯
現在這個帥哥美女
現在都是不談感情的
都是看你的財產有多少
哎呀
你的財產多
先看資產提財
你的資產很多
像之前的大同
哇賽 那個搶翻了
大同好像已經搶翻了
等於在取一個慘嬌子的感覺
對 這是大統
每次講大統就講到資產題材
每年講 每次到董監改選行情的時候就噴一下
因為他有資產題材
第二個呢 轉投資有價值
這也是不錯的
好 那這個角色有這兩種
萬一董監持股很高的話
也沒有人要去跟你搶啊
搶不過嘛
你都80% 我跟你算
我選一期也不能幹嘛
就只能去領領開會的車碼費而已
然後幹什麼
所以董堅持股偏低啊
偏低喔
假如低於10%
哇塞
這也太低吧
我跟你講低於10%還真的很多
很多
低於10%
不是你創立一家公司搞到後來
你持股不到10%
有事嗎
他們都把股票換成鈔票了
偶爾也要把股權買一點回來啊
有些公司就這樣
上市就是為了撈錢
就是為了把股票換成鈔票
所以那些被搶經營權的可憐之人
有可恶之處
可憐之人必有可恨之處
好,那第三個呢
這也蠻重要的
股價淨值比偏低
被低估了
對,因為假如股價淨值比很高
那你去搶它
搶一家公司就是為了兩個
你猜哪兩個
不是人就是錢
對 沒錯
真的嗎
第一個叫做選票
哎呀 趙華真的厲害
這個交往一個人
不是為了他的青春的肉
就是為了他的錢嘛
就為了他的錢嘛
要不然阿姨不想努力
阿姨
看看
我上次看到一張照片
有個阿姨坐在勞斯萊斯上面
阿姨就說
小伙子
看看你能為我做哪些努力
讲得很清楚
所以这个董金改选行情
它就是两个
不是人就是钱
不是为了选票
就是为了钞票
那你股价净值比高
我为了这个选票
我花了大把银子
去换这个选票
也要看值不值
想想也不大值得
那假如股价净值比低
那我现在买了
我買了之後
萬一我沒有選票
至少我還有股票
對呀
我還有股票嘛
股價近日比低
至少買了還划算
所以這個董監改選行情
我們就會從這兩個
去找股票出來
好 去找 可是怎麼找
然後要怎麼選
我們才知道說這個哪一邊會贏
好 那首先我們就要來看一下
這個持股乘數的規定
好規定
要怎樣才能變董監事就是了
又來了
證交法第26條第二項規定
公司十週資本額
假設3億以下
董事就要持股15%
監察人要持股1.5%
不少不少
好 那這個3億到10億
董事就不用那麼多了
10%就可以
監察人就1%
那這個金額越來越大的話
那這個董事我們看
超過1000億呢
董事呢就是
1%就可以
錢不用太多
那監察人呢0.1%
因為1000億太多了啦
這太多了
那這些呢
我們就可以從一個東西來查
叫做董監持股
這網站佛心啊
Good info
什麼都有耶
這什麼都有
Good info老闆你來一下好不好
你是靠什麼賺錢的
你什麼都有耶
這什麼都有
還要讓這些付費軟體混飯吃嗎
不過他還是有點缺點
他不曉得什麼時候選
因為他知道什麼時候選
可是你要交叉比對
還好我們把他全部輸入到以色列
我們可以做一些交叉比對的動作
其實是佛心網站
我只跟你講說
你可以從裡面查董監持股的比例
你看這個八拍的一堆
董監持股
董監持股的張作
你看全体董监持股
这边8%的 7%的
你看这么少
很低
我随便查一桃子股
这个不到10%的
那不到10%的
那你就可以从中看到
其实台股里面
其实有很多股票
董监持股的比例是不大足的
可是他们会不会有一些隐藏版的人
有掌握他们的股权
只是从表上看不出来
对啊 有啊
也有可能
也有这样子的
所以你可以从里面查
但是你要去查一下
到底哪一年選
所以呢
有點累
好
那沒關係
這個我們就直接呢
去找
好啦
小哥有幫大家做統整
我們當然是有統整的
在家裡都做這些功課的啦
好
在家裡不做別的功課
做這些功課
家裡除了做那個功課
就做這個功課啦
好
來看一下
那個
歷年來
這個最經典的董監改選戰役
那我就要想到2017年的榮鋼
那2017年榮鋼我还记得
2016年我在上课的时候
那时候就跟选人说
这榮鋼记得怎么样
记得要好好的买进
因为榮鋼我们已经看到
看到怎么样呢
各位你看一下这个区间买超前15名
在2016年底的时候
这区间买超前15名我念一下好了
第一名叫低金嘉义
他在2016年底到2017年初他一共買了27000張第一金嘉義第二名叫元大輔城
買了14000張
輔城在台南分點嗎
台南
第三名叫大眾新穎
新穎
台南新穎嘉義
這個買了9800張
第四名元大金華
所以聽你也知道又是台南
然後日盛永康
趙峰嘉義 凱基北門
還有富邦欣盈 原富台南
台南嘉義人請朝而出
一頭人家義台南人
好 嘉義台南人
因為榮剛應該在台南嘛
對 榮剛在台南
那到底這些是公司派買的呢
還是附近的市場派買的
我要怎麼判斷
都有
對 剛好附近市場派也說有在他旁邊
台南嘉義的火拼
公司派也在他旁邊
那那
所以一看這個分點還有這個籌碼
就知道幹嘛啦 火拼了
火拼 在地幫派的火拼
那時候龍剛非常誇張
各位你看一下這個主力賣鈔
對
我從來沒看過主力賣鈔這麼長的
是
連續50天主力賣鈔
一直買一直買一直買
這個決心很強耶
50天很困難耶
只要有一天
我休息一下我今天沒有看盤
我整今天變主力賣鈔
對
他連續50天主力賣鈔
各位有沒有看到主力這條線
一直漲一直漲
這代表說市場派跟公司派互不相讓
互不相讓
我們最喜歡這一首
我們最喜歡火鍋
我就怕他一下就讓了
對 我們最討厭那時候對於投降
你盡量買我投降
我就倒給你
我自動我們討厭
討厭死了
我們喜歡怎麼樣
互不相讓
一直買一直買
那時候龍鋼還有個股期貨
哇塞
我靠個股期貨賺的蠻多的
因為就一直買龍鋼的個股期貨
可是我有疑問喔
他買了50幾天
我要怎麼知道他會買50幾天呢
因為他開始買的時候我就跟嗎
我們在12月底的時候就發現
他已經連續買了大概20-30天了
對 那買20-30天會不會買完了咧
通常這樣子啦
這個買完了會有一個徵兆
什麼徵兆呢
第一個盤中你會看到一根大黑K
有人到了
第二個呢
你從盤後會看到主力大賣
主要是這兩個徵兆啦
那時候都沒有
那時候都每天還漲
還漲還漲
從17、18塊一直漲一直漲
最高漲到26塊
當年的行情
當年各位看一下
股價慢慢漲
突然應該黑K
這天黑K 其實很多人很害怕
這天黑K 我的LINE訊息接不完
小哥龍剛怎麼了 你是不是把它賣掉了
我說沒有啊 我在爬山啊
我沒有賣掉 剛那天在爬山
我沒有賣啊 沒關係我們回去看一下草莫
主力還在買嘛
那這個只不過是漲多了一個小回檔
可能中間有人下車
但不是主力
對 就有點有人下車引發了蝴蝶效應
大家拚命賣 變成一根大黑K
後來呢 一下子又在創高
又在跌
修正一下 後面又創高
直到後面這裡比較恐怖
有兩個大黑K
那這兩根大黑K呢
這兩根大黑K在什麼時候
這兩根大黑K呢
已经快要到投票权之日
所以小哥也讲一个很大的重点了
跟怎么跟
卖也要知道怎么卖
好
那我们首先呢
我们要知道什么叫投票权
好
就是你必须在某一天
对
那这一天呢
大概是由龙卷回补前
大概三四天
是
龙卷强制回补前三四天
你必须要在这一天呢
你要持有这张股票
我才有投票权
对
你才有投票权
但是我拿到投票权后
我可以卖掉对不对
就可以卖了
拿到投票权之后
你就有股东的书
委托书什么的
你就可以卖了
除非你后面还要期待
他有卸票行情
因为有些股票
还真的有卸票行情
董监改选拉一波
然后上任之后
拉一波
再拉一波
谢谢
谢谢你
感谢你支持我
谢谢你让你走
因為這個讓一些低檔買的人可以高檔走掉
那龍鋼就這樣子
他在什麼時候
他在擁有卸標權的兩週前
就有這兩根大AK
這兩根大AK出現大概就是要走了
那龍鋼他的董監改取行情
就造了一座山
叫龍鋼山
那這個你只要在低檔有買的
那看到大AK你就記得出掉一些
就是走了
少賺沒關係
這個也沒辦法說你一定要可以賣在最高點
這個很難
那在龍岡當年狀況就這樣
當年也忘了是市場派贏了還是公司派贏了
也忘了
忘記了反正有賺到錢就好
反正到後來
三月多到了賺了
反正我們也不介入經營
我們只是沾醬油吃豆腐而已
賺個價差而已
好啦 來吧
另外一檔
第二檔
這一檔很有趣啊
這檔是市場派
有趣啊
過去的公司派後來變成市場派
再回來逼供公司派
這麼複雜
回來逼供
沒有因為過去的公司派被弄出去了
然後變市場派
再回來把公司派弄的
復屁
復屁復屁有這個概念
復屁概念
那這一檔在2020年也蠻有名的
叫2332的友訊
然后呢各位
我们还是要看一下
他的分点啊
好
那友訊我们也是
很早之前就发现
他有董监改选
行情的痕迹哦
因为呢
他的分点看起来
跟三年前的榕刚
看起来有点像
为什么
友訊又不在台南
这个因为听说
同一个集团干的
那集团专门在玩
董监改选
好
那为什么知道呢
来看第一个
第一個分點國泰那這分點國泰會跟什麼有關因為國泰是股票期貨的造勢商所以呢當我們看到這些分點都進來買
那我們不要打擾它嘛
我們就買股期
買股票期貨
國泰他就負責造勢啦
他就跑去買股票
所以我買股期他買股票
所以國泰買了很多
第二名凱基北門
又是北門
台南人
國標台南
元大大灣
元大歸人
元大金華
元大府城
說真的
如果是友訊
我會搞不懂台南人
幹嘛來繳禍
他們就同一個集團
一個集團
早就在南部都開好戶頭了
那等於說
這些分店
我們也可以留意了
可以留意
如果台北公司
也在董監幹局
也看到這些分店
就想說又來
這個集團又來
又來
這集團又來了
好
那友訊呢
我們就跟著上車
無奈
那一年發生了悲劇
什么悲剧
什么悲剧呢
那一年在过农历年的时候
打开电视
美股绿油油
武汉肺炎
那时候还没有COVID-19
看到武汉肺炎
哇塞
一个人一个人倒下去
对
看到那新闻完蛋了
多单怎么办
结果果不其然一开盘了
春节一开盘
开始大跌
狂跌跌到了三月多
这时候对搜筹码的人很有利
对搜筹码很有利
对
真的是便宜减
对啊
但是對有些人做價差的嚇死了
對
哇塞 我只不過想
這個問個導遊賺一點價差
怎麼從10幾塊跌到了8塊
對 好慘
瞬間這個快腰斬
所以即使有人收籌碼
敵不過大環境的系統性風險
還真的敵不過
真的
因為那時候跌到8500元
所有的人都傾傲而出了
對 所有人都賣了
大家也忘了
他有統監改選這回事了
早就忘了 桃明先
結果後來你知道嗎
後來還真的有統監改選
是
股價沒多久又創了新高
對對對 那一波漲很兇喔
8塊錢漲到20塊
那我們就說
有興到底有沒有董經理改選行情呢
有的 對
他就是被
節奏被打亂了
對 被他害了嘛
莫名其妙送一個生肥的股
這個是很可惜啦
是 好 那後來他們好像選到的人
現在又有蠻多人走了
真的才有這種事喔 大同也有啊
一直請新任的總經理董事長
又一直換 一直換 一直換
大同聽說就是這個市場派的集團
現在就當了董事長了嘛
對,因為他覺得
磨刀霍霍,向資產
對啊,因為請來的人想要永續經營嘛
誰跟你永續經營啊,有事嗎?
對嘛,我們把土地活化
不就好了嗎?那麼費力
對,蓋個房子,賣賣不就好了嗎?
我叫你賣主產,你跟我用功念書幹嘛
要歸納一下
因為剛剛有特別提到
什麼時候上車很重要
什麼時候下車也更重要
不然兩根大黑黑黑
你還不走後面很可怕
歸零了
所以我們操作董監改修行情
我們就有三個要點
第一個
以一兩個月波段為主
這是絕對不能常報的
差不多啦
你看我們現在一月多了
一般董監行情的投票權
大部分都在3月底
因为3月底有一堆融券强制回补
各位你就记得
融券强制回补前两周
你大概就要结束了
那时候你就准备
又可以开始玩
这个子利率行情
董监盖学行情
大概就在一二月玩的
好
就这两个月
这第一个一两个月
不断的时候
第二个呢
很重要
董监盖学行情
第一个
主力肯定是连续买的
好
你假如發現主力沒有再買
那根本沒有董監行員
不可能 因為他要收籌碼嘛
第二個呢 他的股價禁止比最好是低的
因為低的 你買你也安全
我們每次都說 買股票跟吃藥一樣
先講求不傷身體
對 再講求藥效
所以股價禁止比低 買了萬一跌了
至少禁止比低 至少也不會賠太多
那董建持股低的公司呢
你就可以提早付去啦
好
那这股价高点
很容易落在停止过户日前
好 停止过户日
大概一两个礼拜
一两个礼拜
它会公布什么时候
是停止过户日
一样在网站上查得到吗
大部分都在三月底
好
对啊 因为就是
六月份开股东会嘛
六月初开股东会
停止过户日呢
就在四月初三月底的时候
是
好
这就是董建改革行情的要点啦
所以呢
很多的美感
很多的技巧
包括说现在就是每一年的1月2月
会是这个董监改选的热潮期
但是不是每一家董监改选都会上演金银权之争
现在赶快去网站上查一下
谁的董监持股偏低
那当然媒体的嗅觉也很灵的
过不久可能就会有媒体开始发放消息说
某几家可能有董监金银权之争
这时候你就可以开始留意了
那当然要搭配主力的筹码要连续买
那听到这边一定很多的听众
觀眾朋友會想說
那到底誰
今年會有董監改學行情
希望我們直接給答案好不好
好 給答案的話
就要歡迎大家訂閱我們的榮耀班
在榮耀班裡面
小哥有特別的提醒
今年其實可能會走
這樣的行情的公司不多
但是他還是有幫大家選出來
記得訂閱我們的榮耀班了
好 今天非常謝謝小哥
教我們看這個董監改學行情
就是短短兩個月
會有很多的疫情在發酵
大家可外留意
如果是去動手查
其實我們媒體
也常常會有這方面的消息
當然要盡得
最重要的是
它不是一個座長波段的
最多一兩個月
尤其是關注這個
最後過過日
最後過過日之前
只好就趕快先賣掉
少賺一點也沒有關係
希望今年大家學會了這一招
都能賺到錢
那我們今天的歌友
投幣報就到這邊
下次再見會了
拜拜